romantic comedies can be entertaining
and charming
but those cheesy pickup lines are rarely
successful in film
or otherwise even though they're
normally used for laughs
some writers still try to include them
as serious sentiments
here's a breakdown of the worst pickup
lines in movies
intentionally bad or otherwise couples
retreat
directed by peter billingsley follows
four married couples who each are having
relationship problems
one of the couples jason and cynthia
asked their friends to come with them
to a couple's therapy retreat on a
tropical island so they can get the
package right
in one scene dave and ronnie participate
in an exercise in which they pretend
need for the first time after exchanging
names
dave asks ronnie if she has a cell phone
when she asks why
dave responds someone's gotta call god
and let him know one of his angels is
missing
this line is awful mostly due to being
lame it's also lazy and unoriginal
immediately recognizable as opt-used and
insincere
in couple's retreat it is indeed
knowingly bad and acts as a punchline
ronnie responds wow that is the worst
line
i've ever heard natalie portman and
ashton kutcher
star in no strings attached as emma and
adam two friends who decide to begin a
friends with benefit's relationship
the two of course end up developing
serious romantic feelings for one
another
their casual relationship quickly
develops many complications
including emma initially rejecting a
real relationship with adam
after he tells her he loves her emma
eventually realizes she loves him as
well
and the two get together after she
confesses her feelings to him
after this grand moment this happens you
give me
premature ventricular contractions
i'm assuming that's a good thing you
make my heart skip a beat
since they've technically already gotten
together this isn't really a pickup line
per se
but it sure sounds like one it's meant
to be endearing and reflect emma's
character
and it is slightly more original than
many other pickup lines out there
still even portman's charm can't
entirely save this line from being
wince-worthy
directed by burst sears 17 again
introduces mike
who after a freak accident gets stuck in
the body of his 17 year old self
while the main plot line involves mike
rediscovering how much he loves the
family life
he'd become invited against over the
years there's a subplot with
mike's son alex mike who uses the name
mark gold to hide his true identity
and enroll back in high school befriends
alex and tries to help him build his
confidence in order to go out with his
crush nicole
i just i just want to tell you that you
look like my dog nicole is rightfully
confused by this cringy insulting line
alex tries to amend it by saying his
dog's hair is soft and shiny
only to further dig himself into a hole
by talking about how the dog
is now dead it's meant to be a funny
scene although it's almost too
embarrassing to enjoy
still it at least succeeds in eliciting
sympathy for alex
who is clearly very nervous about
talking to his crush
he even admits as much to her
unfortunately things only get worse for
alex who shortly afterward
accidentally lights himself on fire not
exactly the smooth moment he was going
for
in hitch will smith portrays alex hitch
hitchens
a self-described date doctor who makes
his living teaching men
how to successfully date women when he
meets a woman sarah who sees past his
ruses
he realizes there's more to being in a
relationship than the tricks he teaches
hitch first spots sarah sitting alone at
a bar he buys her a drink to take
over to her and introduce himself before
he reaches her
another man beats him to it with the
same tactic hitch stands nearby to
eavesdrop on their conversation
and i couldn't help but notice she look
a lot like my next girlfriend
this line is incredibly arrogant what's
more in this case
it's almost the first thing he says to
her even before asking her name
it's clear he finds it both clever and
forward instead of pompous and
unsurprising
in the context of the film the viewer is
definitely meant to interpret this
pickup line as bad
hitch smirks an amusement over the trite
line when professional lure hitch
does get a moment to talk to sarah his
more straightforward
open approach is meant to be seen as
refreshing he is the romantic lead after
all
sierra burgess is a loser directed by
ian samuels
stars shannon purser as the title
character sierra
is a not so popular high schooler who
begins a text message exchange with
jaime after he mistakenly messages
her thinking she's someone else there
are many problems with this film
namely that sierra is literally
catfishing her love interest for most of
it
at the end of the movie the two get
together even though sierra has not
apologized for any of her lies
and other wrongdoing you're not exactly
everybody's type
and okay thanks but
but
you're my type this line feels both
grossly pitying
and moderately insulting the film seems
to suggest that sierra's only obstacle
to popularity and a relationship with
jaime is her appearance
it's natural for a teen girl to feel
insecure and the movie aspires to a body
positive message
but this line which emphasizes that
she's not conventionally attractive
strikes a sour note it's hard to swoon
over a pickup line with such a backward
message
essentially an entire film about a man
who uses pickup lines to meet women
the pickup artist follows jack jericho
an elementary school teacher who spends
his free time practicing pickup lines
and then using them on various women
when he meets randy
she couldn't care less about the lines
he throws at her so of course
he falls for her in the opening scene
jack is practicing one of his lines in
the mirror
has anyone ever told you that you have
the face of about the jelly in the body
of a digger
by referencing both an italian
renaissance painter and a french
impressionist artist
jack likely believes he's showing off
his intellect while complimenting his
target
if she doesn't get the references that
might just make him seem even smarter
his other lines include has anyone ever
said you have a magnificent smile and
skin invented to be touched
and did anyone ever tell you you're too
good to be true
complimentary questions are jack's mo
apparently
the botticelli de ga line is already
pretentious
and knowing that he's probably used it
more than once makes it all the more
obnoxious
randy isn't impressed has anyone ever
told you you have the face of about to
challenge the buddy videga
the 10th grade art teacher shallow hal
directed by peter and bobby farrelly
introduces hal just as the title tells
you hal
is very shallow he has no interest in
women who aren't super model pretty
when a life coach sees just how shallow
hal is
he hypnotizes hell so that when he looks
at a woman he sees her inner beauty
manifested
as her outer appearance when he meets
rosemary a 300 pound woman
he sees her as a much slimmer version of
herself hal for spots rosemary as she's
walking into a department store
he promptly and well somewhat creepily
follows her inside
she's shopping for underwear and holds
up a pair in her size
from hal's perspective a skinny woman is
holding up a large pair of underwear
and he doesn't understand why building a
parachute
it's an uneasy moment viewers are likely
both cringing at hal's obliviousness
and sympathizing with rosemary as hal
continues to put his foot in his mouth
talking about how big the underwear is
rosemary merely glares at him and walks
away
hal follows her explaining that he
didn't intend to offend
and was just trying to be funny rosemary
is confused but accepts his apology
still hal moore then earned his way onto
this worst list with that line
she's the man is a modernized retelling
of shakespeare's twelfth night
after her school cuts the girls soccer
team viola hastings
pretends to be her brother sebastian at
his new boarding school so she can join
their boys soccer team and play against
the boys team at her old school
while pretending to be sebastian viola
falls for sebastian's roommate
duke orsino the situation becomes even
more complicated because duke has a
crush on olivia
since biola cannot confess her feelings
to duke while disguised as sebastian
she must offer her advice to duke when
he asks for help
talking to olivia viola tells duke to
pretend she's a girl
he's interested in so they can role play
a conversation
duke complains he doesn't know what kind
of questions to ask anything
ask me if i like
cheese duke laughs at the suggestion but
asks anyway
they end up talking about how they both
like buddha it's a cute moment that
shows viola and duke have chemistry
still when duke uses the line on olivia
in a later scene and she responds with a
confused and annoyed look
it's clear that the line was not such
great advice
in bridesmaids annie is asked to be the
maid of honor at her best friend
lillian's wedding
the bridal party experiences hijinks and
mishaps in the days leading up to the
wedding
the group decides to go to las vegas for
the bachelorette party while on the
plane
one of the bridesmaids megan sits next
to a man
john who she insists is an air marshal
despite jon's protestations to the
contrary
megan then corners jon as he's exiting
the airplane's bathroom and says
hey not air marshall john you want to
get back in that restroom and not rest
the line turns out to be not nearly as
effective as it is funny
john tries to get back to his seat megan
continues to make suggestive comments
and even lifts her leg resting it on the
wall
to block his path in a hilariously bad
attempt at seduction
jon eventually makes it back to his seat
shutting down her string of pickup lines
but as it turns out megan was right
about jon being an air marshal
not only that but the viewer also finds
out at the end of the movie that megan
and john began a relationship
still we wouldn't recommend trying this
tactic
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one